you tuber verse Tyson here Startalk next
summer school is in session this is
Startalk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and we're coming
to you from my office of the Hayden
Planetarium of the American Museum of
Natural History right here in New York
City and this edition of start talk
we're calling summer school yeah said
yeah the professor Fred Charles Lou
Charles welcome thank you so much for
having me I love summer school you love
summer absolutely I got my co-host for
this episode Matt kirshen Matt hey
welcome back thank you so much all right
host of probably maybe science probably
science it could be science nearly it's
not short for science I can't believe is
no science probably science a weekly
review of science current event that's
exactly it's excellent access the
podcast keep that going keep that going
Charles but professor yes at the City
University of New York so it kind of
equals here this is a cosmic queries
version but it's called summer school
people just trying to catch up that's
right with stuff they might miss or get
ahead or get ahead I forgot summer
school forget your head right for
motivated students and with that in mind
I think let's start off with a quite an
academically advanced question let's do
it Cooper Holland on Instagram asks how
hard would I have to fart to knock her
thin to escape velocity also wouldn't
sunrise be a good time to try it
mmm that's Cooper Holland from Arizona
State from ASU ASU huh I'm coughing
because I'm imagining how much gas needs
to be used to make that happen
but the reality is first I assume you
have an escape velocity from the Sun
right no he wants to escape from the
earth oh he wants to escape from you I
thought he wanted the earth to escape
from the Sun oh that is up for an ass's
yes
earth into escape velocity that's harder
than just if he wanted to write but
earth would be a lot harder because
Earth's orbital velocity now can't get
that picture out of my head he's
positioned on a gantry yeah yeah solid
fuel or liquid fuel rocket oh yeah that
would be no that's just air pressure
that's just a yeah this was really a
poison unit pneumatic rock do you like
it like a the co2 pellet right right
like pneumatic yeah Wow now I see
Earth's orbital velocity is about 30
kilometers per second per second right
around the Sun you have to take the
square root of 2 of that and so that
makes time 1.4 times 30 is about 42
kilometers per second there's mass is
about this is a cute little fact that
whatever is your orbital velocity around
what you're warming if you multiply that
by the square root of 2 that's the speed
to escape that object yeah it's a very
cool fact it is it's neat it's nice
coincidence in math and then the Earth's
mass of Toria to 0.4 yeah yeah Earth's
mass is 6 billion trillion tons right so
to generate the amount of impulse
necessary to get earth that much mass up
to that velocity and that's a lot of
cans of beans yeah because you it's a
momentum thing so you need enough expel
gas so that the recoil of your planet
can be meaningful and significant right
and correct me if I'm wrong but you'd
also have to make sure you're in some
way tethered to the earth so you're not
just block and drag the earth with you
right otherwise you would just fly off
at a tangent right yes right so I think
ideally you'd want gay all humans
involved in right you'd need holding
onto a tree or something you'd also need
every cow in the world
just put them all together mmm I think
that's a very good summer school problem
calculation to do
yes Cooper good luck but in principle
yes yeah so in other words if you are in
space the various ways you can actually
set yourself into motion but to do so
you have to lose mass from your body
either gap through gas liquid or solid
yeah and if you're at sunrise that would
be a good time because the best way to
inject that extra velocity the Delta V
is in the direction of the orbit the
tangent to the orbit so not straight out
as some people might think but actually
out at a 90 degree angle so you can
build with to the speed that the earth
has itself yes right okay
by the way but all that methane that
could be pretty dangerous it's true one
match that's it yeah that's a flare
that's a ball so that's a greenhouse gas
yes it is oh yeah yeah yeah yeah very
potent more potent than co2 true so you
really have to light that yeah so but
they would like in the space you're all
that weight if you leave earth yeah I
need the greenhouse gas that's right
it's the balance it's the balance yeah
Wow
it's very exciting you know what I think
I'm gonna have to assign that to my
astrophysics class next year and then
the Dean will call you it maybe Cooper
will help me out with them hmm well well
we are doing calculations at home
Foreman on Facebook asks is math a
discovery or an invention beautiful
beautiful don't get me started I wanna
hear Charles four okay well remember
that my wife is a mathematician yes yes
right I am my wife has a PhD in
mathematical finance right yeah
twinsies so we got math going in family
here yeah and my son also given a choice
of either studying math or astrophysics
in college has chosen math anyway that's
okay we still love you sorry yeah I know
I know such a discipline I when did you
know what the signs I was that
when he was a little kid putting
refrigerator magnets and strange shapes
I knew that something was up something
something was that hiding something
something wasn't in her anyway math is
something that exists by itself but
mathematics as we use it and formulated
today is an invention of humans this is
a clear reality of the universe because
things will do what they're doing
whether we understand them or not and we
created math in order to try to
understand and reproduce and utilize
those things that nature provides for us
so for example when the ancients were
building pyramids they invented geometry
right those pyramids would have stood
anyway if we had put them together and
not known the equations but with the
equations the ancients were able to
build them properly the same is true
with say rocket equations that allow us
to send things out into space we could
have sent things into space without
knowing how to do the calculations but
we wouldn't have had much control over
so bottom line the math you see in
textbooks today or in papers we humans
have invented that following a set of
rules that Nature has provided for us as
a template Neil I'm okay with that
okay I'm okay I don't like debates about
whether one word or another word best
describes it I'd rather say that maybe
our language needs yet a third word that
perfectly accounts for it and then we
get rid of the argument altogether that
would be a discovery or an invention
it's the word between the two that we
don't have disco vention it's why we are
now the max acts mad math oh yeah yeah
you might have is it or is it a wave in
quantum why we arguing that it's both we
just don't have a work we tried we tried
wakil but it didn't catch on wave in a
particle so so III just don't sounds
like some sort of branding exercise from
the 80s
70s disco vention okay the fact that
math works at all as a tool to decode
the universe is evidence that the
universe at least the parts that have to
revealed itself to us follows logical
repeatable repeatable patterns and math
is simply a way to code for logical
repeatable patterns so it's remarkable
that math can describe the universe at
all except that math is a perfectly
logical system and so is the universe
put them together of course it's a
marriage made in heaven
very much like music right math music
that kind of connection and the bee gees
understood that well with their song
calculus calculus and I thought calculus
was an emperor of Rome I'm gonna give
the brother of Clavius why we're talking
about things I'm gonna combine two
different questions together so Eric
Hanson on Facebook asks I recently read
that if all of the space were taken out
of every human on earth the resulting
mass would be about the size of a cube
of sugar
how then anyone adequately explained how
the entire mass of the observable
universe was once was at once a point
only microns wide and then I'm gonna
complain this with this other question
this is a question I could have thrown
it out straight afterwards but I thought
okay I'm gonna leave this just in your
subconscious to bubble over while you're
answering that one from Ashton Norton
also on Facebook other than the Big Bang
are there any other scientific theories
that have been discussed as possible
explanations for where we came from well
so those those two together or separate
as you choose okay so this is basically
a cosmology question sure right so I'll
take the cosmology question number one
you can take cosmology
question number two I'd like both
alright I'll answer each one joke okay
use half alright leave me a little room
at the end alright so the reason the
universe is so different now than it was
back then is simply because there were
some kind of physics that happened
between the moment of the Big Bang and
the present day that we still don't yet
understand it is completely true that
the universe back then the density of
the universe right around that moment of
the Big Bang at the Planck time would
call it was approximately 10 to the 97
kilograms per cubic meter all right and
that's pretty dense yeah and even if we
took out all of humanity we're back in
the 60s now you have 72 60s we get it
yeah absolutely
you said it we have a circumstance where
the matter of that density is so removed
from anything we can think of that that
human beings the size of a cube of sugar
analogy when you move all the space that
density is still only about 10 to the 15
kilograms per cubic meter so there was
just another state of matter its I
thought it's not even that complicated
okay okay if it stays as solid matter
just taking out all the space between
the particles yeah you're not going to
get much smaller than that but at the
temperatures of the early universe
matter is not stable as solid matter it
it's energy and you can pack energy into
any kind of small volume you want so
that's a fair way that is the character
a fair way say it and so as a result the
the laws of physics that were governing
that behavior produced something that
eventually evolved into our universe
today and we have yet to decipher
scientifically the processes that went
from that to now that's I have to
tighten that it's not that one of the
internet went from then to a little bit
after then because we know what happened
a little bit after then until now yeah
that's fair that's good physics yeah
yeah
and by a little bit after Neil I think
you're referring to 10 to the minus
yeah yeah yeah so zero point there's a
gazillion of a second so we've managed
to trace it back a very long way yes
what that last bit really that's right
and and that segues into that second
part of the person where what is going
on in that tiny tiny fraction of a
second that is so different from what we
know today in our universe and so that's
where the speculation can lie right what
could have happened other than a Big
Bang as we understand it today could
something else have generated the kinds
of energies and effects that have led to
the way the universe expands today
there's lots of speculation was really
really hard to be able to decipher or to
pinpoint the physics involved it's we're
adding extra dimensions we're adding
extra particles we're adding all kinds
of extra crazy ideas and none of them
have yet panned out in a scientifically
verifiable way and let me just say do
you think we're happy about a big bang
yeah that's a great point this is like
weird stuff all right but evidence
points to that the universe we now
occupy can be described by what happens
if you had a big bang as as accounted
for with a small dense hot early
beginning and it gives us the the amount
of the hydrogen and helium and neutrinos
and and and the age and the density and
the distribution all of this comes out
of that if you have a better idea
fine we'll take it but until then we're
stuck with the Big Bang how's that
there's another way to think that's a
great point okay yeah the imperfections
of a scientific theory drive people nuts
we want theories to be perfect
right they're not and that's where the
science and little learning but what you
don't know is whether the addition is
just an add-on or whether you have to
throw out everything to come up with a
new idea do you think that lost
gazillion of a second will be explained
or even explainable we've got top people
working on it right now
they call string theorists yeah top
people and cosmologists in general yeah
top people mm-hmm string theorists is
just one group of promising paths but
all of cosmology is really about trying
to get that last little tiny bit Chris
Colton on Facebook asks why aren't we
expanding with the universe if we are
part of the universe I get asked that
question a lot and I my students and I'm
gonna add a coda to that will I ever
break six foot are you still growing
we're still well I'm and exact gonna
help you there we will get to the answer
to that when we return for a second
segment of summer school star talk
back in our second segment of Startalk
summer school when you have to go to
summer school you got to bring in the
big guns
Charles Liu professor thank you new
Professor Charles Lu CUNY Staten Island
Matt kirshen the little gun a little you
like five five five five and 120 pounds
yep
eight and a half stone let's peaceful
choose me it's good eight and a half
stone yeah cuz Britain really doesn't
know what units to you where metrics
sometimes and sometimes you know in some
cases were ahead of you we do fruit and
veggie metric we normally do Celsius for
temperature but then we'll do stones
yeah you have issues you have metric
issues we're comparing things to the
size of animals is oh that's where the
stones come from yeah whose hands whose
feet so we left off at the first segment
a question about yes if the universe is
expanding and we're part of the universe
why are we not expanding mm-hmm the
answer is electromagnetic forces see the
expansion of the universe is its own
thing but it does not counteract on
small scales things like atoms and
molecules pulling one another or
electrons and protons or literally they
have molecules in his pinky that yeah
point right so as he picks his fingers
on his hand that's an excellent point
yes so the reason my pinky nail is not
expanding away from my pinky finger is
because they're being held together by
other kinds of forces way stronger
forces in the shorts in the short just
in the short distances yeah so out at
the distances of millions or billions of
light-years the expansion of the
universe dominates even galaxies are
carried along for the ride but on scales
of humans or even planets really those
other forces are much strong in the
solar system is not expanding it has
okay cuz I always I've been given the
analogy in the past of the blowing up
the balloon and watching the dots get
their parts on the surface that's right
but is it is it then almost more like
sort of blowing up
a globe that has like ice sheets
floating on it but the ice sheet state
the ice sheet stay in one club that is a
correct better yes assessment and they
become further apart as the globe
expands yeah on a balloon if you drew a
galaxy on it that galaxies get bigger
better so if you put it like little
sticky notes on the balloon and that
would work right sticky knows this I
have the ability to slide lifesavers so
the sticky notes themselves are the
lifesavers would become further apart
but within themselves they stay the same
sides correct you got it okay
yeah something a lot better now good
question we do we do yeah what an
excellent audience unless they just
called from no I'm sure these are will
check with our researcher Matt next all
right from Ben Ratna at Ben makes TV on
Twitter oh that guy I've heard of that
oh yeah
Ben says please describe the laws of
physics it sounds like we're doing Ben's
homework oh I'm gonna pull rank here you
ready go ahead okay in one of my books
yes I have a chapter called on earth as
in the heavens oh that is all about the
effort to discover laws of physics on
earth and the question about whether
they apply in places other than Earth
hmm and it's not a given that that
should be the case okay it might have
been that something you discover your
earth is different on Mars or different
on but it turns out it's not it's the
same what I would be interested in is
not necessarily the laws of physics
because that's what I live with all my
life do you yes do you have a choice
what are the laws of psychics I don't
understand well laws of physics right
yeah natural stuff predictable whatever
but the laws of psychics like people who
make predictions about the future people
who cast themselves as those who
understand things that are beyond nature
what are the laws of psyche
maybe they're honourable laws well then
why is there a major in psychic studies
not in any university I know it was
astrology yeah there's an Arizona yeah
it's like that other than Arizona I
don't think any accredited university
has a major in astrology or psychics
yeah yeah but surely if such a major
does exist then there must be some laws
that they must follow okay I've never
been curious about that maybe there
should be no no yeah yeah we can get the
headline you've never seen yeah yeah
psychic predicts winning lottery number
a second time that's true you don't have
to cheat oh you don't get that that's
true well we'll have to ask this
question there yes what Ben makes TV
thinks about the laws of psychics okay
but otherwise the laws of physics are
very simple yeah yeah I mean they fit
you know if you hit okay I remember I
was in school yeah somebody's taking an
accounting class oh I saw the book that
they were carrying aha it had like a
million pages in the book yeah and my
book which was on like all of
gravitational physics have I get third
that many pages so I can understand the
whole universe based on what's in my
book but they need a book four times a
fad just to be able to do somebody's
taxes fair enough
and I said because you can't deduce the
tax code yeah the good thing about
physics is you learned some rules and
then all the rest derive from them
pretty much very powerful you know when
I'm in every soften the top someone
comes along and goes actually those
rules are all slightly wrong yeah
Newton's F equals MA you got equals
mc-squared yeah I got Maxwell's
equations yeah we're done pretty much
yeah throw in a few
quantum physics the glaciers yeah years
worth of physics study is just F on one
side force and then MA
mass times acceleration on the other
side and you just change F in a
gazillion different way as you change MA
in a gazillion different ways and that
that spring spring summer souls for free
yeah absolutely yes I mean absolutely
beautiful great question all right
I really enjoy this question because
apart from us it came from a four year
old Oh
the four year old son after four year
old son of pin T from last asks house
nice
why do punctured balloons fly around
chaotically why doesn't it fly on a
straight line wonderful question
the when you have a rocket actually you
know how they travel in straight lines
and were always very impressed right but
which we don't see is the amount of
control mechanisms and structures within
the rocket that makes sure the exhaust
comes out in a very orderly and a very
directional fashion right when you
puncture a balloon the exhaust that's
coming out is coming out in a way that's
poorly controlled it's not a pinprick
hole for example just there's a
difference you can try this if put a
little tiny hole in a balloon as opposed
to a large hole in the balloon the
larger the hole the more chaotic the
flow goes so it's a matter of whether or
not you can control the air coming out
in a reasonable and or linear way
compared with whether it's just rushing
out all at once well also you'd want the
movement of the air to line up with the
center of mass of the balloon yeah okay
and so if that lines up then the balloon
will just be pushed in one direction if
the Jets air is coming out at an angle
different from straight to the center
mass you'll start rotating the balloon
right plus a balloon is not symmetric
there's a little the bottom of it would
you get the yeah not the knot so the
boone's weight is not symmetric and the
center of the mass of the balloon would
also move around as the Bema deflate yes
yes that's right so what you'd have to
do is configure something like get a
straw maybe yeah to guide the air a
little better have some stabilizers and
then you can make a balloon rocket yeah
that would be a lot of fun but I love
that question it's a correct sounds like
a kid that's that's tearing up birthday
parties I want that kid on my research
step so by the way most of the time when
you pinprick a balloon it blows up right
right so you have to do this carefully
yeah I learned as a
if you put a piece of tape on the
balloon uh-huh then you poke the hole
through the tape then the rubber or the
outside like flexible stuff doesn't
rupture in a rip and you just get a
little hole and you can have it go
you've done this before
of course hasn't everyone know I haven't
put tape on a balloon to puncture it Oh
give it a try son but this is way more
fun to just pop them it's too fast
yeah it is too fast it's too fast to set
yeah you're correct I will try this from
now on any masking tape word I used like
plastic and visible tape okay okay stop
Prive oh my god now you put on both
sides of a blue there you go there we go
start spinning that would be fun
all right four-year-old balloon
experiments yeah I like that so pulsar
prove on Instagram says hi quick
question how would you explain neutrinos
to dumb teenagers who know nothing about
astrophysics okay okay
and the question it doesn't make clear
whether they themselves let me jump in
right now and say that there are no dumb
teenagers there just aren't I'm an
educator and maybe I'm showing my bias
here but I've never found an actual dumb
teenager they can be pretend to be dumb
they may think oh yeah but they're not
actually dumb I want people always to
feel like that they are smart because
they are and not have to act them or
pretend to be dumb to be cool all right
so there's no such thing as a dumb
teenager that's just my opinion sorry
had to get it out there now to answer
the question a neutrino is just a little
tiny particle that comes out so that in
atomic interactions nuclear energy in
nuclear interactions energy is properly
balanced okay both in the motion and in
the amount I think that's really what a
simple way of describing energy it's
it's a pretty weird particle because no
one knew they existed and there was an
imbalance in the experiments that we're
being done in nuclear physics and it was
Enrico Fermi yes who said there's got to
be a particle carrying away this
momentum there has to we're looking we
don't find it's got to keep looking it's
got to be what properties would have
which can't have any charge
she's gotta be neutral and it's got to
be really low mass a little so it's got
to be a little and neutral and well the
funny thing is it's so in Italian
neutrino right like Bambino Newton so
it's just the diminutive version of
right neutral neutral or of a neutron
right but the funny thing is when this
was first proposed the neutron had not
yet been discovered mm so when the
neutron was discovered people like oh is
this it did more calculations no no
that's even smaller than the neutron
that has no charge right so yeah it's
got it's it's necessary to what's going
on in the universe but it's very hard to
stop it plows through anything
what's the number of neutrinos go
through your thumb every second from the
Sun many trillions trillions many many
trillions and if you look so how do they
don't interact and that's why they're so
they were so hard to do that but they do
interact very minimally right we can
detect them and it was one of the great
experiments in astrophysics that allowed
us to find neutrinos coming out of the
Sun what happened was that people took a
very large vat of dry-cleaning fluid
very pure put it down more than a mile
below the surface in a in South Dakota
and surrounding things just a
pre-existing salt mine was it was a gold
mine
Oklahoma State gold gold mine not salt
mine and it was sunk all the way down to
the bottom they put it there and they
surrounded it with a lot of cameras and
so they just watched this tank of very
pure cleaning fluid and when a neutrino
hit even though trillions and trillions
passed through every second they might
only get one neutrino hit every wrong
once in a while and when that happened
there would be a flash of light and so
they'd watch it and make sure the flash
of light is not caused by anything other
than a solar neutrino and that's what it
was
so it was every it turns out that that
particular molecule perchlorate it
needed the chlorine and yeah it had a
special nice property that it would when
hit by a neutrino and with that
interaction
very rare occasional interaction would
cause the flash how long ago did that
experiment happen is it reasonable
decades now several decades ago the gray
Davis jr. was the experimentalist John
McCall was the theorist that was got the
Nobel Prize yes that's not John McCall
yes yes people didn't fully understand
that you have the theory and the
experiment and the observations they all
have to come together to make to make
that discovery that's correct and but
that was a real triumph and it led to a
secondary discovery actually because
turned out that the number of neutrinos
that were being detected from the Sun
were fewer than we expected and so for a
moment people thought wait a second is
the Sun dead and we just don't know it
yet it was known as the solar neutrino
problem because those neutrinos had to
be produced in order for nuclear fusion
to be going on so if they were half as
many as we expected then maybe the Sun
itself was starting to run out of fuel
scary scary prospect turned out though
that it was just something happening in
our upper atmosphere called neutrino
oscillations another amazing discovery
yes so it be I throw you a basketball
but you catch a football right so the
experiment was designed to detect
basketballs and but you're actually
receiving footballs and what it is is
someone in between us is swapping them
out that's right and it was amazing that
was what was her yeah these neutrinos
come in different flavors it turns out
yeah who knew who knew at the time okay
so there isn't just one neutrino
particle there's three okay three
different kinds electron neutrinos tau
neutrinos and neutrinos and their
antimatter counterpart and the anti
Matic had really six yeah that's pretty
cool physics is amazing isn't it I love
summer school
great question sir school question all
right Kyle Ryan top on patreon asks
ignoring the cold could a settlement
survive on the surface of Pluto
what would radiation levels be like are
there any useful resources other than
water ice hold me back get to that
question when we return star talk
Matt before the break you you had a pedo
question it is yeah I mean Pluto have
history but we buried the hatchet long
ago well whether it's a planets or not
could a settlement survive on it oh well
you can ask why would you want to do
such a thing
right because but just take for example
Charles yeah is there a line of people
waiting to settle in Antarctica
no and Antarctica is warmer and is balmy
and wetter than Pluto penguins eat a
penguin right so Pluto in principle in
principle we could just pitched into
anywhere you just bring enough resource
Yeah right yeah the settlement could
survive there as long as you could
shield yourself from the cosmic rays
that hit it and as long as you can keep
yourself warm because the temperature is
so low out in that distance food you
need no way to generate how faint is the
Sun if you if I was standing on the
surface of Pluto and staring straight to
the Sun which I presume I would be safe
to do the that Lux is only about one
1,600th the amount of flux that we get
from the Sun here on earth is that much
I thought I'm going on a memory now not
on a calculation that the Sun from Pluto
is about like a full moon night here
it's brighter than the calculation there
well absolute magnitude negative 26 for
the Sun and minus 15 no 12-14 magnitude
team that's a factor of seven yeah so 10
to the fourth that's 10 to 14 no not
quite that much yeah seven magnitudes
there five yeah so - that's so it's a
factor of 100,000 right so it's a little
bit and you said if I said 1,600 because
so for tau right well you just easier
okay so yeah so there's everybody's not
PO to find out if we're you in the
middle of an active calculation poll
page no no this actually brings up a
very good point and I teach this to all
my students and since this is the summer
school
episode is quite appropriate you have 40
plus 40 times farther away from the Sun
than Earth is Mount average and so it's
1 over that square that's right so
that's that's where you get this one
1600s as bright that's right but but the
idea that a person is were square law of
light very cool
the idea that a person can just pull up
the answer on Google faster than we can
do the calculation brings up a really
important point about school in general
and education in specific you might
agree with this Neal we can no longer
think that we are educated if all we can
do is memorize facts or calculate things
that can already be calculated and sit
on a database we have the world's
information at our fingertips the only
way that we can remain viable as a
productive member of society or as a
civilization is if we are better than
Google we have to do that and I'm just
not picking Google so that's like he
doesn't wanna be replaced with a robot
yeah does that sound like that to you it
is absolutely right we all can easily
replaced by a search engine our
education system our learning our
interaction with nature and with the
world and with other people must be
better than the surgeon we know we know
the Chou's is a better singer than
Google so I think that was Charles or
stump speech right there yeah well we
are talking about singing and the like
Marcus and I'm gonna apologize for
butchering this name gooey Mara's I
apologize if that is way off on patreon
asks I had a debate with a friend of
mine where he said the scientists hate
art I think that's not true could you
please tell us something about the
subject art no way you know I don't know
a first I don't know any scientist who
hates art a B many scientists I know not
only just don't hate it but love it see
the one of the books behind you on a
shelf is called mathematics and art a
book written by an art curator who has
fascinated by the role of science as it
has influenced art and
I was privileged to be asked to write
the foreword to that book and as the
writer knows I'm a big fan of the starry
night by Vincent van Gogh 1889 and so I
and and I'm not unusual in this regard
there are colleagues love music love art
on levels that you might not even know
or suspect because generally if they're
in the news it's not because of that
it's because of the science they're
doing oh no no we're we're art loving
community all the way back and why do
you see why do you think universities
they call the schools of Arts and
Sciences we go way back with that two
sides of a coin each the pinnacle of
human creativity and expression one
constrained by the universe the other
constrained by imagination itself
science and art I could not say it
better Neal it is absolutely true
science and art are inextricably
intertwined
there is no scientist I know that
doesn't like on have him take up that
question with Leonardo da Vinci
absolutely and Albert Einstein himself
wrote in 1930 that the sense of the
mysterious the wish to be awed by things
we don't know is the root of all great
art and science and I agree with that
statement
Treena Jennings on Facebook asks if we
can figure out the center of the Milky
Way galaxy smells like raspberries can
we figure out what things would smell
like elsewhere with the center of all
galaxies smelled like Rossi said the
center of the galaxies mind oh it's a
cute press release about people who are
looking at molecules in clouds and
turned out that the detected certain
aromatic compounds which are found in
raspberries okay so they said oh it
smells like raspberries oh it smells
like raspberries because there are these
volatile organic compounds that are in
gas clouds near the Milky Way galaxy
center there's also a lot of ethanol
there too yes like so - smell ya smell
like
and I think the pronounce right right
you know that's right still yeah so this
is a lot of organic molecules at base so
and there's even some sunless tanning
lotion to DHA in molecules over there so
you can not only get a great suntan I've
never lost a smell yeah yeah I didn't
know such a thing exists so so so it's a
little deceptive to say that space
smells like that space smells like
nothing unless you put molecules where
you're sniffing and their molecules
everywhere and so there it is that
you're smelling molecules in space right
rather than space of light so to answer
that question and constructively the
answer is yes as long as we can find the
molecules that create certain smells in
our brains through our noses in a
location we can tell you exactly what
that smell smell precisely but there are
a lot of particles out there and they
can smell like a lot of different things
yeah nice who wants a relativity
question bring it on yeah Hussein said
Hwanhee
on twitter says I am still having a hard
time understanding the concept of how if
your twin is on earth and you travel at
almost the speed of light you will not
aged as much as them or something like
that ins can you really try to dumb it
down or using analogies again for before
Neil so no I'm not saying that I'm out
of this one go please don't use the term
dumb down
we are not dumbing things down we are
merely translating the concept into a
language that everyone can understand
can you smart it up that's right thank
you Matt okay here's the basic point
smart it down
time is experienced at different rates
for people who are traveling at
different rates of speed that's a very
very complicated concept if you're
trying to lock it into our idea in our
regular time that a second is a second
is a second but the moment you
acknowledge the possibility that time is
a dimension like length width and height
and you can move through it at different
speeds then the twin paradox that is
here or other paradoxes become not too
difficult because what you're doing is
measuring time intervals right you're
not measuring actually the amount of
time at this very instant but you're
measuring the time from the time you
experience one minute to go to the time
you experience a minute from now that
person who is traveling at a different
rate through time and space will simply
experience a different interval and
you'll both call it a minute yeah but
relative to each other there are
different links so yeah only realize
that once you come back into contact
with each incorrect yeah that's right
that's right and the way to know who
will be younger because both of them in
motion will say that the other one is
ticked they're the opposite clock is
ticking slower is that the your twin who
went out had to slow down turn around
and come back and that breaks the
symmetry it's called a paradox because
if I see you traveling and your time is
ticking more slowly and motion is
relative and you see me I'm actually
standing still but as far as you're
concerned you're staying still and I'm
moving you see my tongue time ticking
slowly how is it that at the end of this
exercise one person is younger than the
other right how do we not know like if
yeah the train is going pause the
platform rather than platform is going
past the Train one of the great jokes
against Einstein who said hey I said
when is Grand Central Station arrive at
the next train people everyone was
trying to get their head around this so
it's so it's it's specifically the
acceleration of the the one too young
who goes out on the relationship and
goes out and then turns around it comes
back that strikes the symmetry right
it's that acceleration and deceleration
there yeah the whole thing it's either
positive or negative acceleration but
it's just the wouldn't matter it's an
acceleration there one that leaves and
comes back that's the one that is the
thing that appears to be well so it's
it's it's an uncomfortable concept
because we don't experience that in
everyday life that's right as our active
senses do it was not necessary to know
this on the plains of the Serengeti
mmm-hmm
to avoid getting eaten by a lion you
didn't get to know relativity but it's
absolutely necessary in this day and age
of atomic energy and very very high
speed
Matt it's time for lightning round oh
yeah okay nice see if the bell works it
does
alright so charlton I will try to answer
him sound bass
alright well we're gonna jump back from
Einstein to Newton deejay Milky on
Instagram says I read a few years back
that the earth is technically falling
into the Sun but doesn't actually go
into the Sun is that true yes and the
reason it doesn't go in is because it's
traveling at orbital velocity around the
Sun yeah if we if we traveled any slower
sideways we would fall towards get
closer to the Sun so we are falling
towards the Sun but we're being held up
if you will by a very high sideways
speed so yeah we got this and Isaac
Newton first demonstrated this in an
keep me baby print Capilla and first
drew it in the system of the world
that was his cliff notes for his
Principia terrific written in English
what a recall alright you got it
alright code monkey I a on Instagram
says what causes the Earth's magnetic
poles to move and what would cause the
magnetic north and south to flip ah very
good question our magnetic field is
created by the dynamic motion of
ferromagnetic materials inside our earth
iron yeah almost almost all iron and
because of that because it's fluid and
it moves that's why our poles move it's
as if you had a dancing magnet inside
but it's kind of somewhat semi solid
someone liquid and it rotates but not
exactly the same rate that earth does so
all these dynamics influence which
direction on Earth's surface you find
the North and South Pole and whether the
North is up or down relative to it and
history has shown that the poles have
flipped multiple times in the past yeah
next about if our if birth cools
completely and the core becomes solid
that's Megan feel shut sauce frozen yeah
it's done
good good all right uh it wouldn't shut
off too many feel to the movement to the
magnetics right good good okay Aaron
Harrington on Facebook says if the
universe is infinite - then how could
time exist other than the meaning we
give it if the universe is infinite is
the key coin point we don't know
necessarily yet that the universe is
infinite he's saying if it's infinite
let's let's change the question suppose
the universe had no beginning and no
known end is infinite in time and space
what does it even mean to have a
calendar mmm great what are you
measuring well what kind of a paraphrase
of that question I think so yeah yeah
yeah and and what we would be measuring
in time is the various atomic processes
going on in our bodies and a clock like
this definition of a second is just a
way to macroscopically allow us to know
whether we're getting older or whether
we're not so you need vibrating
repeating phenomenon to measure time
accurately at all so in a universe where
nothing repeats there can be no
measurement of time well what do you
think of that if you can measure the
passage of time or define the passage of
time as the expansion of the universe
then you don't have to have the
vibration you can just have the change
that's going in a single direction from
smaller to larger okay you so time then
it gets measured by size yeah size of
thing right interesting rather than
repetition Matt last question go for it
all right I'm gonna go with this one
then Billy from Queens here out of blue
to college for College City University
of New York oh yeah cosmically curious
on Instagram said what are some tips for
an everyday astrophysics student who
wants to become an extremely successful
science educator who reveals books I
don't know I really love it when
educators express their knowledge in the
language of the people who are listening
in other words a really good science
educator is essentially a very good
interpreter a very good translator not
someone just dumbs things down not just
someone that turns things into sound
bytes but someone that can really take a
concept that's sort of it's described by
math and science and turned into English
or French or whatever language that the
person is fluent in that is the mark of
a true science educator thinking about
the audience and not necessarily about
the source oh I can't I can't touch that
other than to add punctuation and say
that Galileo an academic fluent in Latin
when he decided to write about the
weather earth was in the center of the
known universe or orbiting the Sun he
wrote that in Italians knowing that the
common folk would be able to then
embrace and appreciate the discoveries
he was making and so that was quite a
striking fact that's like Carl Sagan
appearing on The Tonight Show yeah yeah
that's your crossing hibbott a moment
you're crossing boundaries there and
then he became a regular guest on The
Tonight Show coming to the people where
do people with where the people are
right and and never like claiming that
he was somehow smarter or better than
they were empowering people to think
even more highly of their own intellect
that maybe they only just discovered for
the first time well said sir we got to
end it there Charles
Neal dude dude love you man love you to
me family everybody's okay everybody's
good last night check excellent
excellent
Matt it's been a joy when you come back
anyway like 10 pounds more or something
growing tall we don't expect that but
this is Jim somewhere see if I can
weaken those electromagnet then you'll
get it but always good to have you so
ways good to be Hank you probably
science is going strong that is the
focus yes look that up on the podcast
you've been listening to and possibly
even watching this episode of star talk
our Edition called summer school I've
been your host Neil deGrasse Tyson and
as always I bid you to keep looking
[Music]